as long as i got a professional sports
guy on i'm gonna ask you a couple of my
simple questions okay fire away at me go
ahead all right number one where do you
stand on this whole golf controversy
what do you think of these guys chasing
the money
joining that live tour live tour that's
backed by saudi arabia from a
competition standpoint i don't know why
you would do it because the best events
and the best golf courses the venues are
still in amer are still in the pga tour
so going out there in a 54-hole event no
cut where everybody gets money to beat
52-year-old golfers i don't know why
that would excite you that would not
excite me my competitive juices like
your juices my juices you want to beat
the people in front of you there's
nobody they beat so that but if a guy if
a country you know somebody made this
point i was very much against it because
the saudi arabia and all the uh you know
human rights abuses and all that stuff
and khashoggi and all that but
he said you know howard we're deal we're
we're dealing arms to them for you know
hundreds of millions of dollars why
should golfers be held to a different
standpoint
and that is the second place i'm going
the nba owners got 20 billion dollars
wrapped up in uh the chinese government
where well there all of a sudden mother
teresa when it comes to countries how
about that right
right right how about nbc uh who's got
deals with the ioc
and the nbc has put the olympics in
beijing and so she russia if you were a
golfer and they offered you 200 million
dollars
you wouldn't do it we have taken blood
money in sports in the u.s government
forever
so that would not prevent me from going
but i wouldn't take it because winning
some dopey tournament in london is not
the same as playing in a ryder cup golf
i'm gonna ask you about this you got a
situation where the yankees are the best
team in baseball the mets are in first
place are the mets going to choke again
and can the yankees win
number one the yankees are 50 and 18.
when you're 15 and 18 you know that is
an incredible stretch of 68 games uh and
the yankees have good pitching they play
very good defense the yankees have a lot
of pressure on them because you can't go
have this regular season and then blow
it into play-offs the mets are very
intriguing and a very interesting story
box show walter who has been bouncing
around a long time he's a very good
manager he's never gotten a break and
the mets are have very good pitching
they got a resourceful offense they
don't strike out they have their
20-something games over 500 the mets are
a very very good and a very dangerous
team and here's the intriguing thing
about it i think a yet yankee met world
series is very very doable this year
how's that i'm excited by your answer
i'll tell you another thing that excites
me about sports i love
that tom brady retired then he unretired
and then he signed the deal to be a
broadcaster on fox
will brady will brady win another super
bowl before he finally hangs it up go
ahead he's gonna have a chance but i
will say no you know rob gronkowski just
retired as you know the tight end
uh i will say no i think he's pushing
his luck a little bit we all know he's
the greatest quarterback of all time we
all know he's an incredible competitor
i'm not sure about him working on fox i
don't know if he's going to be that
great as an analyst why would he not be
a good analyst the man plays he
understands i i just don't think he's
going to be open enough i don't think
he's going to want to criticize
fellow quarterbacks you're saying in
order to be great you got to be a little
bit controversial absolutely yeah and he
is uh he's everybody's pal right